a nearly 30-hour barricade situation in
the south valley ends and the suspect
is in custody thank you for joining us
at five i'm brian loftus and i'm denise
valdez
hostages were involved in all of this
including a young child
it happened at a motel near blue diamond
and dean martin that's where arko mana
joins us now live with the details orca
denise and bryan metro police say the
suspect in this
case took a four-year-old boy and his
babysitter hostage when he barricaded
himself
inside this motel here behind me it was
an extremely dynamic situation that
ended peacefully
with no injuries and those two hostages
are now safe
metro says this all started yesterday
yesterday around 10 30 in the morning
when a metro officer saw the suspect
described as a hispanic man
trying to get away with the stolen
vehicle a fight started and then the man
went to pull
a gun out from his vest the officer
stepped back due to safety and the
suspect ran
into the motel we're told he fired his
gun toward officers while inside
he then used a hammer and a saw to cut a
hole in the wall so he could get into
another room
that's when he took the four-year-old
boy and his female babysitter hostage
crisis negotiators talked with the
suspect for hours
and he eventually let the boy go
yesterday and then after negotiating
overnight
and into this afternoon the suspect left
the baby center go
around 1 30 police were able to finally
convince him
to surrender extreme care
and patience and de-escalation was used
throughout this entire incident
this is the kind of thing that the lvmpd
swat team and negotiators train for
and prepare for and there's nothing more
important to us than the sanctity
of life and that those hostages and that
the subject was taken into custody
without any injury the suspect faces
several
charges including assault with the
deadly weapon kidnapping
and attempted murder on a police officer
again a very dynamic situation out here
that is now ended safely with those
hostages safe and the suspect
in custody reporting live tonight orca
mana 8 news now